okay I've got a great book
recommendation for you today it's been a
while since I read one of his books but
today's book recommendation is a hero of
France by Alan first and that's fu rst
I've read a lot of Alan firsts work and
he I can't say that all of his work is
in this sort of universe but a lot of it
all that I've read is historical fiction
based in Europe during World War two and
he actually lived in Paris for a long
time and the book I most recently read a
hero of France takes place in occupied
Paris 1941 during world war ii and it
follows a a member sort of a leader
really of the French Resistance named
Matthew and the stories are fantastic I
mean Alan first the the writing of the
stories the storylines are excellent but
the entire atmosphere of world war ii
europe particularly in France is it's
just such a pleasure to read and this is
a story that includes you if you like
suspense the story includes suspense if
you like a romantic element or
relational element to the story it
includes that if you're interested in
getting sort of the flavor of what Paris
was like at the time it includes that
it's both fast paced but has really good
character development and I absolutely
loved it I already have picked up two
more of Alan First's books that I'm
going to be reading and they all sort of
take place in a similar atmosphere not
always France some of them in other
countries I believe Spain for one and
now I'm not sure if I'm getting confused
but I thought he also wrote a historical
fiction novel taking place in Spain
during the Spanish Civil War I believe
but in any case my recommendation today
is a hero of france by alan first there
is a list of all of my recommendations
at david pakman.com slash
recommendations and if you use the links
most of the items i've recommended and
this includes documentaries this
includes
books nonfiction fiction etc for most of
them we have an Amazon link at david
pakman.com slash recommendations now i'm
recommending these to you no matter
where you buy them but if you use the
Amazon links at david pakman.com slash
recommendations when you buy any of the
books or films or anything that i
recommend we get a kickback and that's
particularly important because of what's
going on with the youtube advertiser
boycott so again
alan first book a hero of france is my
recommendation today you can check it
out along with all of my other
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations